MILES WARD: Hi.
My name's Miles Ward.
I run solutions architecture
here on Google Cloud.
But this isn't my first cloud.
I made the switch 3 and
1/2 years ago from AWS,
and I've been talking to a
lot of customers and partners
that are in the middle of
trying to do the same thing.
See, they learned the
basics about public cloud
from AWS's training and
certification programs,
but they're looking at the
features of Google Cloud
and the sophistication
of our technology
and really eager to apply
that to their problems.
So we thought maybe
we should put together
a training course that
leverages that existing
expertise, your familiarity
with AWS's public cloud,
and allows you to apply
that to our new generation
technologies.
Maybe you want to learn
more about a system that
allows you to automatically
scale from no connections
to a million connections
in under a second,
or a system that can
process petabytes of logs
without ever having
to manage an instance.
Maybe you want a system that
doesn't quite cost so much.
We're about 60%
cheaper on average.
Or maybe you're just
tired of complexity,
and you want a cloud
that is easy, easy, easy.
This training course is
designed just for you.
It's about six hours long.
The first hour and a half covers
the fundamental differences,
the design differences,
between our cloud
and Amazon's, helps
you understand
and maybe be able
to better guess
how our system helps you
build the tools you're
trying to build.
And then 4 and 1/2 hours
of fast-paced, deep,
hands-on labs that give you
firsthand experience with
our infrastructure-as-a-service
systems but also our platform
as a service,
database as a service,
both relational
and non-relational,
functions as a service, all
manner of tools that make this
such a rich suite.
We think that this course
enables you not only to take
on your first experiments
with Google Cloud,
but prepares you in the right
way for future endeavors
and exploration.
I'm excited about this course.
I just took it.
I thought it was
really informational.
And I think you'll have
a great time with it.
Thank you so much.